la parole est à présent monsieur
philippe Dominati pour le groupe Union
pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mais chers collègues ma question s'est
adressée le Premier ministre puisque
c'est lui qui devra arbitrer dans
quelques jours le financement de la
société d'État du Grand Paris mais je
suis très satisfait Madame le Ministre
puisque vous avez été quelques jours élu
de Paris qu'il vous est désigné pour me
répondre le concept du Grand Paris a été
développé par Nicolas Sarkozy pour faire
en sorte que la métropole parisienne ou
francilienne garde son rang dans le
monde et deuxièmement pour résoudre un
problème immédiat
urgent la congestion des transports en
Île-de-France
il y a le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
tacle le maire de Paris
quand les berges sur scène encombrent
économiquement et et s'étonne du coup
économique de cette décision il y a des
biscuits entre les Verts et la majorité
socialiste sur le Pass Navigo ou sur le
financement de tel ou tel organisme de
transport pourtant il reste 9 milliards
à trouver pour améliorer les transports
en Île-de-France et l'État ne paye rien
ce sont les entreprises d'Île-de-France
qui payent 45% du coût global ce sont
les entreprises
Île-de-France qui payent 75% du coup de
furian actuellement et le reste ce sont
les contribuables avec un impôt
spécifique la taxe d'équipement un impôt
spécifique c'est 20% du coup et donc
voilà qu'on apprend que de nouvelles
sources de financement sont attendues
que le premier ministre va trancher
est-ce qu'il va demander une
augmentation des impôts aux Parisiens et
aux Franciliens est-ce qu'il va demander
une augmentation des impôts aux
entreprises parce que l'activité
économique est trop forte dans notre
région c'est cette question que je
demande je vous demande des engagements
des engagements clairs n'augmentez pas
les impôts ne taxez pas les entreprises
et prenez vos responsabilités vous
voulez que l'État commande et bien que
l'État paie merci la parole est à madame
Cécile Duflot ministre de l'Égalité des
territoires et du logement
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Dominati s'est
passé original votre façon de présenter
ce dossier parce que si le dossier du
grande Paris Express a une spécificité
c'est qu'il a fait un moment un grand
consensus à la fois sur ses modalités de
financement et sur son projet grand
consensus pour une raison assez
désagréable finalement c'est qu'il avait
été largement sous évalué quand je dis
largement c'est qu'il manquait 10
milliards 10 milliards qui n'avaient pas
été évalués initialement 10 milliards
alors que ce projet avait a suscité une
attente considérable chez les
Franciliens
10 milliards alors qu'il est absolument
nécessaire y compris pour l'activité des
entreprises ferroviaires françaises que
nous lançons ce dossier voilà pourquoi
le choix du gouvernement a été de
travailler sur un redimensionnement de
ce projet pour faire baisser ce coup
final de 30 milliards sur les moyens de
mobiliser différentes sources de
financement pour réussir à financer
l'ensemble de ce projet pour répondre
aux attentes des élus de toutes les
collectivités locales et de toutes les
couleurs politiques croyez bien que ce
qui unit un certain nombre d'élus autour
de ce projet c'est la nécessité de
répondre aux besoins de déplacement des
Franciliens mais aussi de répondre aux
futurs besoin de déplacement la
saturation de certaines lignes en
Île-de-France est aujourd'hui
identifiée vous feriez référence aux
taxes affectées à la Société du Grand
Paris ce sont des taxes qui ont été
décidées par le précédent au
gouvernement et voté par le Sénat et par
l'Assemblée nationale pour financer ce
projet comme ce qu'il se passe dans les
autres pays du monde il est nécessaire
évidemment que tout le monde apporte une
part l'État et ce sera fait le premier
ministre qui est engagé pour les besoins
en dotation de la Société du Grand Paris
mais également que des contributions qui
permettent de financer ce projet qui
sera phase et dans le temps soit faite
évidemment que l'équation est compliquée
quand on fait la promesse comme la fesse
précédente le fait précédent
gouvernement de porter un projet à 20
milliards d'euros alors qu'il vaut 30
milliards il est certain qu'on laisse
une situation qui est extrêmement
désagréable à gérer néanmoins et parce
que nous avons la volonté de tenir cette
promesse qui a été faite de l'État et
qu'il y ait une continuité des
engagements le gouvernement et
l'ensemble des collectivités locales
dont la région est de France dont
l'ensemble des départements continue de
travailler sur ce dossier le Premier
ministre annoncera le 6 mars le scénario
qu'il est possible de faire pour
répondre à une attente qui se fait
chaque jour de plus en plus criante
merci